salem craig congratulations you've made
it into the final round of fortune and
fire
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to create an iconic blade from
history
[Music]
the egyptian kapesh
dating back to 2500 bc the kapesh was a
curved sickle sword adopted by egyptians
from the canaanites it was used to
execute their enemies as an infantry
weapon and also as a symbol of the
authority of their nobles
the unique shape of their curved blades
meant they can be used to hook a shield
snag an opponent's leg in an attempt to
trip them or even tangle an opposing
weapon
the weapon's distinctive design makes
the kapesh easily recognizable in
television series such as game of
thrones
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
good luck man
i'm excited about getting back to the
comforts of home and knock out a really
nice weapon
job number one it's got to be strong
because the capisce is the original
battle axe
we're going to use the floor of the shop
to get the vision going
that's what we're going to build
those egyptians man
they had their act together i didn't
like them wearing dresses but other than
that they seemed pretty cool
today i would like to get the profile of
the copics done and making that first
bend is pretty much gonna be the moment
of truth
most weapons whether it be a knife or a
sword is a straight-line drug
but this has got to bend so once the
bend is put there you can't straighten
it out and move the bend because you've
compromised the material too much
i think it's too long
i'll shorten it up
last night i was able to finalize my
design
if i could catch up and forge in my
profile this morning that'll be great
i need to restrict my habit of losing
track of the time when i'm working on
something i wanted to make kind of a
distinctive damascus for this kopesh
it's similar to what you would term a
merovingian twist pattern there's
something that you might have found in
the ancient swords made by the
merovingian franks
[Music]
i'm gonna be trying to twist it up to
make the pattern cooler but i've never
tried it with a bar this thick
this is the difficult part i've got a
twist but not past the point where it's
gonna rip apart on me
this morning i had to go back to the
forge and i readjusted the blade we have
a curved blade right just the sheer
weight of that long material just
heating it up it's gonna warp it
the quench is the make or break moment a
lot can go wrong
you know it's like you guys are gonna
hear either major cussing or yippee
if this warps bad i have to start over
come on baby
i'm afraid to wipe it back and see if i
got it or not
yes
yippee
because i twisted the steel billet for
this blade it's possible that it may
untwist in the quench
i hope i'm not visited by the tink fairy
now
that's when your blade goes pink and you
know it cracked in the
quench fingers crossed
oh that looks pretty good
today we just have to cross your t's and
dodge your eyes
i've sharpened my blade i got an edge on
it and now i'm ready to go for the test
let's see if the single cut
i've got a piece of lumber all the way
from japan it was grown in an orchard by
a small samurai
i thought one day craig this lumber will
give its life for you
[Music]
there's no damage to the blade man it
looks like that'll do i really like the
way the sword turned out and i'm gonna
give salem a run for his money
yesterday i finished my blade
i feel like the two most striking things
about this weapon are the bold damascus
pattern and the integral construction
it's all forged out of one piece of
metal very simple but hard to pull off
well i'd hate to shave my face with it
but it's pretty darn sharp for arm hair
i hope that craig's toe patch turned out
really awesome because my blade deserves
some stiff competition
cool basements it is said that the
historic design of the kopesh evolved
from a battle axe its edge was so sharp
that it said it could cut through just
about anything to test the sharpness of
your weapon i will see how well it cuts
through a sandbag a sugar cane and a
rope salem you up you ready yes sir
[Music]
well salem it definitely is easy enough
to cut through a sandbag cut through
sugar cane but the forward weight being
a little bit tip heavy was a little bit
harder to slice through on the upward
stroke but definitely it's a very sharp
weapon
this sir will cut good job thanks
craig you're up you ready yes sir
well craig
it cut to a sandbag cut all the way
through three sugar canes but the same
idea on an upward swing for the test it
did lacerate the rope but it didn't cut
through
but overall
it will cut
now it's time to move on to the kill
test
to test the functionality and lethality
of your blade i will attempt to rip off
the shields then deliver killing blows
on this ballistic dummy let's see how
much damage your weapon can do salem
you're up you ready all right
[Music]
the hook on your tip does allow to rip
off the shield
the edge you have right here cause some
serious damage
enough to cut all the way through the
belly here at the same time i've cut
through all these bones from the
clavicle through the ribs
[Music]
this sir
the keels
craig it's your turn you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
well craig
what i like about your particular hook
design over here is that as you puncture
twist and rip out everything that you
have in there will hook and come out
with it
the edge cut all the way into the bone
and broke these ribs to stir them this
sir
will kill
thank you
gentlemen what i'm gonna do to test the
strength of your weapons is take seven
blows against these animal femurs salem
you're up are you ready great
now salem in examining your weapon we
noticed a small delamination on the back
of the blade
i was not expecting that i'm just hoping
that the edge stays hard so we're going
to keep an eye on that through the
testing and we'll see if it opens up
[Music]
well say on that that did a job on those
bones now there's a little bit of
deflection on your blade
but that back mark didn't open or split
at all
now you can see i went through two of
those bones and was well into the third
well done thank you
so craig it's your turn you ready let's
do it all right
[Music]
well craig you can see
a lot of chips right there in the impact
zone
the first few blows against those femurs
it started cutting really nicely broke
through the one but as we started to
lose edge here with those chips and
deflections it just stopped cutting it
was more of a bludgeoning impact blow
but i felt it really cut well when i was
swinging it all in all nice design i
like your handle construction
and it's definitely a chopper
so gentlemen
good job
salem craig in just five days you've
both delivered your own unique versions
of the egyptian kapesh
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one winner
[Music]
salem
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations
good job thank you
good job to you too
craig you surrender your weapon
all right thank you this experience was
harder than i thought it was gonna be
i need about three gin and tonics and
i'm just gonna make a bad man in the
back of my head go away
salem it's safe to smile now because
you're the fortune fire champion the
recipient of ten thousand dollars
congratulations
[Applause]
the fullers on that blade just really
bring that pattern out i think that's
really nice touch
that's just crazy
it's going to take a while to sink in
kind of stunned right now
you